MARK MIRCHANDANI: Active
Assist recommenders
can help proactively uncover
a lot of opportunities
to improve things, including
the performance of your Cloud
workloads.
Imagine this scenario.
You've got a web server
and an application server,
each hosted on Compute
Engine virtual machines.
An update to the
application server
was rolled out two
weeks ago that added
a bunch of new features.
Since then, there's
been an uptick
in the number of timeout
errors on the web server
when it attempts to communicate
with the application server.
It seems that performance
has been compromised,
and it's starting to
affect the business.
How can you avoid this
scenario from happening
in the first place?
One way is by keeping an
eye out for opportunities
to improve performance.
Let's see how Active Assist
can assist you with that.
It's not always
easy to figure out
what could be causing
performance issues
and how you can
improve the situation.
When it comes to Compute
Engine instances,
an ideal place to
start is making sure
that you're using
the correct machine
types for your workloads.
In the previous video, we talked
about how the VM machine type
recommender can help you reduce
costs by offering rightsizing
recommendations.
Remember, applying
rightsizing recommendations
that resize your VM to
a smaller machine type
will let you avoid
wasted resources
and optimize for costs.
However, when resource
constraints are detected inside
of your VM, rightsizing
recommendations
to resize to a
larger machine type
will optimize for performance.
The VM machine type recommender
will recommend a larger machine
type when it identifies
a VM that is persistently
throttled by
insufficient resources,
such as CPU or memory.
Here, an n2-highcpu-32
offers a better fit
for the memory used,
as well as offering
the CPUs that are actually
needed to run the workload.
In our scenario from
the start of this video,
this very well might have
resolved those performance
issues.
These recommendations
are created
by analyzing data from Cloud
Monitoring over the past eight
days.
Compute Engine offers a
number of standard machine
types with fixed CPU
and memory amounts.
If none of those fit the
requirements identified
by a recommender, a
custom machine type
might be offered with
appropriate amounts
of CPU and memory.
Rightsizing
recommendations aren't
just limited to single
instances, either.
You can also receive rightsizing
recommendations for VMs
in a managed instance group.
These recommendations will come
from the appropriately named
Managed Instance Group
machine type recommender,
but they work very much
like the single instance
recommendations.
This is especially useful
for cases where you may not
be able to increase the
size of the instance group
or for workloads that just don't
work well with auto-scaling.
For Managed Instance
Groups, metrics
are collected and
analyzed from all
of the instances in the group.
That way, the
recommendation won't
undersize for any of the
individual instances.
As always, you know
your workloads best.
When you receive
those recommendations,
you can choose to
review and apply
them or just dismiss
them and hide them
from the Cloud Console.
You can always view
them in the History
page of the Recommendation Hub.
Beyond just virtual
machines, there's
a few recommenders
that can help you
maintain or improve performance
of other Cloud resources.
For example, if you're
using Cloud SQL,
you can receive recommendations
from the Cloud SQL
out-of-disk recommender.
These recommendations come
from looking at the disk space
usage of a Cloud SQL instance.
By analyzing the storage
utilization trends
over the last 30
days, recommendations
can be generated if an instance
is likely to run out of space.
The recommendations
will suggest either
manually increasing
storage capacity,
enabling the ability to
automatically increase storage,
or deleting data to
free up disk space.
Active Assist can help
you be proactive and avoid
downtime or
performance issues that
could be caused by running out
of disk space on your Cloud SQL
instances.
Performance issues can
be tricky to deal with.
The recommenders
we've looked at today
can help you stay on top
of performance issues
by analyzing usage data
and suggesting ways
to fix resource constraints.
You can check out
the documentation
to try these out for
yourself, and don't
forget about the
Recommendation Hub
where you can see all sorts
of helpful recommendations.
Stay tuned for the
next video, where
we'll look at some more
recommendations that
will focus around strengthening
security in your Cloud
environment.
See you there.